this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e i have had so much
tea in my life i've been to china i've
lived in china in japan i've done tea
tours i drink a lot of tea and 10 years
plus a physical experimentation and
tracking has shown me many things chief
among them that gut health is critical
to just about everything and you'll see
where tea is going to tie into this it
affects immune function weight
management mental performance emotional
health you name it i've been drinking
fermented poo air tea specifically
pretty much every day for years now poor
tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome the
problem with good poo air is that it's
hard to source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why peaks fermented
poor tea crystals have become my daily
go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them through my friends dr peter
attia and kevin rose peak crystals are
cold extracted using only wild harvested
leaves from 250 year old tea trees i
often kick start my mornings with their
poor green tea their poor black tea and
i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the black specifically
is amazing it's very very it's like a a
delicious barnyard
very peaty if you like whiskey and stuff
like that they triple toxin screen all
of their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic mold contaminants
commonly found in tea there's also zero
prep or brewing required as the crystals
dissolve in seconds so you can just drop
it into your hot tea or i also make iced
tea and that saves a ton of time and
hassle
so peek is offering 15 off their
priorities for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer simply visit peaktee.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available to listeners of this
podcast that's peak t dot com forward
slash tim the discount is automatically
applied when you use that url you also
have a 30 day satisfaction guarantee so
your purchase is risk free one more time
check it out peak t that's p i q u e t e
a dot com slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance
so you can cover your bases if you're
traveling if you're just busy if you're
not sure if your meals or where they
should be it covers your bases i've
recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
[Music]
well hello ladies and germs boys and
girls
damascus this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm going to keep this intro short in
terms of my normal preamble my guest
today is dr ayanna elizabeth johnson
and dr ayan elizabeth johnson is a
marine biologist policy expert writer
and brooklyn native she is co-founder of
urban ocean lab a think tank for coastal
cities and co-creator of the spotify
slash gimlet podcast how to save a
planet on climate solutions which i
started listening to
this past summer
every morning as i drove to the gym and
i became hooked on it for a bunch of
reasons that are not immediately obvious
i suppose she co-edited the best-selling
climate anthology all we can save and
co-founded
the all we can save project recently she
co-authored the blue new deal a road map
for including the ocean in climate
policy previously she was executive
director of the weight institute
developed policy at the epa and noaa and
taught as an adjunct professor at new
york university dr johnson earned a ba
in environmental science and public
policy from harvard university and a phd
in marine biology from scripps
institution of oceanography she
publishes widely including in the new
york times the washington post and
scientific american she's on the 2021
time 100 next list and was named one of
elle's 27 women leading the charge to
protect our environment outside magazine
called her quote the climate leader we
need and quote you can find her online
at ayannaelizabeth.com
on twitter at ayana eliza that's
e-l-i-z-a on instagram at ayana eliza as
well
urban ocean lab can be found at
urbanotionlab.org
the all we can say project can be found
at all we can save dot earth we'll link
to all the social handles for all of
these things in the show notes at
tim.log podcast and so now without
further ado please enjoy my wide-ranging
conversation with dr ayana elizabeth
johnson i learned a lot i had a great
time laughed even a few times hopefully
make you laugh a few times
and
please enjoy
i'm sort of stepping back from doing
public stuff for the year as you know i
sort of like pushed this off for quite
some time so it's gonna be
this will be one of the few things that
i do this year so no pressure but just
[ __ ] nail it on the questions
well let's just dig into that first so
why aren't you doing public facing stuff
and why did you say yes to this the
short answer is i'm writing a book which
means you need as you know long
stretches of uninterrupted time ideally
to actually think
about really interesting ways to to
frame things and there's a lot of
research involved in in that project and
i'm trying to adhere more and more to
this the philosophy of essentialism
which i'm sure you're familiar with
which is a process
so that's sort of like the
the professional reason i'm like focused
on this one big project this year but
the personal reason is
you know that that sort of cultural
perspective that when you have your
photograph taken it steals a part of
your soul
that you know sort of traditional
understanding in a bunch of different
cultures and
that's how i've felt after the last two
years having like my name and my face
and my voice
everywhere
i just feel like i need to gather the
pieces back up and as an introvert i'm
just done with the world how long can
this pandemic last i would like to go
out for a drink at a bar alone
and watch other people and like bring a
book but i i've been like weirdly fine
being isolated
so yeah so that's the other piece of
that just wanting to re-gather my energy
and have time to read and think some new
thoughts you know you get into this rut
of like saying the same things
over again if you don't have time to
really
process new information and figure out
what you think about it all
yeah absolutely sounds like
a period of soul retrieval as some might
say gathering the pieces i actually
was just thinking as you said that
when you mentioned repeating yourself
thinking of a friend of mine named josh
waitzkin who
long ago i was asking for advice around
speaking engagements because it was all
new to me i didn't expect no one
expected the first book to do anything
and suddenly i was kind of foisted into
this speaking
world and he described to me why he
stopped and that was he was repeating
the same things and it started to become
calcified and he started to become
inflexible well he didn't phrase it that
way but he recognized that he's
synonymous with calcified so yeah yeah i
mean he didn't have the room or the
space to
develop his thinking any further
on the topics he was speaking on i think
a period of hibernation is good for
everyone right yeah and i'm trying to
think of it that way
so we'll see and so why why do you say
as to this
because i have a group text
the consensus opinion of which is always
correct and i asked the group text and
they said i should do this
oh wow all right
thank you group on the group text
yeah we've got like a finance executive
a journalist and a hollywood executive
and me in the group text so whatever you
need we've got like
the answer
so how did this group text how did this
group assemble i don't know if i have
permission to tell the story the magical
group text
to be continued let's talk about marine
biology
yeah if you're open to it i'm interested
it might be
a little known fact i want to be a
marine biologist until i was 15 or so
i grew up out near montauk as a townie
way out by the hamptons and my mom took
me to meet frank lundis at one point who
was the inspiration for the crazy
shark hunter in jaws quint
and he had the record for the largest
great white caught on rod and reel so my
interest started with sharks quickly
then expanded with this textbook called
fishes of the world and i just i read
that
all the way through
my younger elementary school years i
would spend my recesses reading this
book so i just turned around to see if i
have it on my bookshelf i do not i have
the diversity of fishes and coral reef
fishes textbooks
but not not fishes of the world sorry
not vicious of the world so i want to
know and i'm sure you've spoken about
this before but i think for setting the
table it's going to be helpful
how did you first get bitten by the bug
and was there a specific creature
that catalyzed that i think a lot of
kids who have a positive experience with
the ocean at a young age
totally fall for it head over heels it's
amazing whatever you like it's in there
doing something weird whether it's
sharks or
for me it was just the coral reef
ecosystem existing
to see through the bottom of a glass
bottom boat
this whole other thing happening
just blew my mind
and
i had follow-up questions
and so it all started for me when i was
five on this i guess that's the magic
age when you're supposed to choose what
you want to be when you grow up and it's
a really common dream job marine
biologist
and i guess i'm just like super super
stubborn and i'm like no really
but my parents took me to key west
florida it was i think one of two family
vacations we have run on we were you
know a working class family we weren't
getting around
and i learned to swim that summer and i
went on a glass bottom boat ride and i
saw crawley for the first time and all
these like crazy colorful fish and just
this whole other thing going on and then
we went to the aquarium and you know
they have these like touch tanks
and they had starfish and sea urchins
and i got to hold a sea urchin in the
palm of my hand and they have tube feet
on the bottom they have like hundreds of
tubes coming out of the bottom of this
like hard shelled spiny thing and that's
how they crawl across the palm of your
hand or
a wreath
and i was just completely blown away by
this like purple
spine waving
foot suction scenario that was happening
these like aliens that actually live on
our planet
and then looking in a tank and seeing an
electric eel
do its thing i was like
what is this called this is my job now
when did you
realize that
you had what it took to make it a career
path
or that
you could find the support to make it a
career path yeah does that make sense
because i had the dream but i just i had
no exposure or maybe not enough
stubbornness and then i ended up
shifting
probably have enough stubbornness i
don't think that was the thing
yeah well maybe not enough directional
stubbornness like so many people i had a
lot of dream jobs that was just the
first one after that i was learning
about the civil rights movement when i
was you know around 10 years old and i
decided i wanted to be a
very specific dream job the lawyer that
got the next martin luther king out of
jail you don't die but you're super
helpful
and i was like that's that's the thing i
can do right i can defend the good guys
and
then
i went backpacking for the first time
and was like oh park ranger is a job
like you could get paid to hang out in
the forest
sign me up obviously best job
and then in college i was majoring in
environmental science and public policy
and i thought oh maybe i will do
environmental policy or environmental
law
and
i
took environmental law as an undergrad
in the law school
and i studied abroad in the caribbean
i sort of nailed this i studied abroad
in turks and caicos
it's a tough job but somebody's gonna
it's a super tough job i mean i have to
memorize the latin name of every coral
reef species right we had tests
underwater with like a slate route to
write down everything they point at and
actually one of the things they pointed
at
i was like i'm sorry what are you
pointing at and they're like over there
and i was like
i don't see it it's like just in the in
the water
i surface and i'm like i want to get a
good grade on this test right like i've
studied so hard i can't tell what you're
pointing at and he's like the thing that
i'm not going to swim closer to because
it might not be a good idea and it was a
reef shark
so like a reef shark on my quiz that day
but we were studying like not just the
ecology but also the
economics of
fisheries management and the policy
piece and i realized that it was this
really cool puzzle
that ocean conservation is actually not
just science it's also
economics and policy and
culture and communications and
protection it is the park ranger and the
lawyer and
all that in one i basically figured out
how to have all my dream jobs at once
so i didn't say that i necessarily
had a moment when i realized that i
could be a marine biologist
i had a moment when i realized i could
get a phd in marine biology
and then never do any research again
but know enough
to be able to understand the papers
to be able to translate that science
into policy making
and to be able to be hopefully useful as
a communicator on these topics as well
so you're just nothing but net you
figured out the voltron of career paths
he's like luke skywalker you're like
shooting that out
death star at the very end it's like why
choose
and and it's weird
people ask me what do you do and i'm
like i don't know i like write things
and i read things and i talk about stuff
and
try to get laws changed and whatever the
thing is so to me it's about projects
and collaborations as opposed to
research per se which is a bummer
because hanging out underwater is pretty
cool too
i have to ask just because i've never
come across anyone quite like you and
i've interviewed a lot of people and i
will say just also as some backstory
this past summer was the first time i
came across your name and i came across
your name because
i i like a lot of what alex does and i
was on spotify looking at new podcasts
and i saw how to save a planet
and
began listening and very quickly it
became my morning routine where i was
going through the back catalog
and i would go to the gym and i would
listen to these episodes
i became so such heavy weights because
you were like i would save the
i was getting a huge jacked ripped
tan even which it doesn't i can't even
explain it your hair was very bad the
whole thing my hair was growing back all
the good things were happening
it actually had the opposite effect in
the sense that i became so engrossed
with certain sections i was like i can't
exercise while i'm listening to this i
actually have to be driving or something
else that is
a little less i was going to say less
dangerous although statistically it's
probably not true
but
the i do have trouble counting reps if
anything else is going on i understand
you know we can't be good at everything
and
my question for you which had a very
strange segue to get here but what
superpowers if you had to answer this
what superpowers did you
receive absorb from your parents who
and from which parent okay
i should preface this by saying my
parents are
incredibly cool
like i will never be as cool as my
parents and i think because i sort of
acknowledged that very early on i was
like okay this is great
my mom grew up on long island in a big
irish catholic family both of my
grandparents on that side are from
newfoundland
and
she became a high school english teacher
she taught starting in the 60s in the
south bronx in bed-stuy in like super
rough neighborhoods just really wanted
to make sure those kids got a good
education and like didn't manage to get
through high school without really
learning to read and reading a bunch of
books and processing that
and she
and my dad met because their best
friends were dating this is sort of like
the long version of the story my dad had
just moved to new york from jamaica he
grew up in kingston
and
i like the long versions by the way we
have nothing
and so i have this like very interesting
sort of like irish jamaican mashup going
and those two cultures are actually
quite similar as i've learned more about
irish history in the last few years just
like you know the way that the british
screwed over the irish and the way that
that shapes your culture and the way
that that influences the music and the
dance and the way you find joy amidst it
all right
that sort of like gets passed down in
the irreverence and sarcasm and so
that's that's where this ass comes i i
definitely think i'm like more sassy
than my parents definitely more chatty
they're both sort of sparse with
conversation
so my mom actually after i finished
college she was like when did you learn
to like
tell a story
and
make jokes because we definitely didn't
teach you that we had the sort of quiet
and not so lengthy dinners i grew up as
an only child
so
from my dad who
passed away a few years ago
super artistic
was an architect
and a potter
and
he
started what may have been the first
black owned architecture firm in new
york city and dealt with just like the
insane racism of that very insular field
and so they're sort of like uh
i'm just going to do this
i know this will be hard but like this
is the thing
and i'm just gonna figure it out so him
with his partners sort of made that work
and
i'm sort of embarrassed to say for many
years i thought he was a failure i
didn't understand
because he wasn't doing a bunch of cool
buildings he could show me he
wasn't making any money really at all
and so i didn't think it worked
and then i ended up hanging out with a
bunch of architects
a few years ago
and i mentioned oh my dad was an
architect and they asked me about him
and they're like oh we we know of that
firm
he opened doors for so many other black
architects
he was the first him and his partners
were the first and to be the first is
not always glamorous and people don't
usually remember you in most contexts
right
and so now i just i was always proud of
the sort of meticulous nature of the way
that he approached things he was
incredibly proud about everything from
his
building plans to his handwriting to his
fashion sense
and really trained my eye as far as
design and style
my appreciation for art but that
that sense that
the thing that he instilled in me was
that i had to give back
this was the mantra to whom much is
given much is expected kind of thing and
also just the like you're gonna have to
work twice as hard to get half as much
because you're not white and i was like
damn it
those are more like the lessons than the
super powers perhaps but i guess you
know on the super power side it's just
caring about how things look
i think within the climate and
environmental movement people don't put
enough often energy into design right
for so many years it was just like this
sort of like
unappealing crunchy mess you weren't
like oh that's where all the cool kids
are
and so i do think about aesthetics in my
work in a very deep way because of my
dad
which is not a superpower in other
fields but might be
more so here
and my mom is just a super deep
researcher so she
ended up developing all these new
curriculums for
her classes
to include writers authors of color
black writers asian writers native
american writers and so she was reading
all these books she was buying them all
with her own money
literally taking them in shopping carts
to school at the beginning and end of
every semester handing them out to the
kids
and just finding ways to help people
have a greater understanding of the
world using literature as a way to teach
history as a way to teach
cultural competency as a way to teach
about morality and justice
and so she's just you know a lifelong
consummate teacher and i think there's
there's a superpower in
the curiosity that she still every day
wakes up and wants to understand more
and more nuance how the world works
i don't think i have it as strongly as
she does i'm like oh my god the deluge
of information like it's too much i
would like to know less
sometimes but i think i would say her
sort of endurance
intellectual endurance and
her real desire to have other people
understand the important things that she
learns
i have no idea what i was gonna say
i'm not sure if i had more time to think
about it if i would say the same thing
well that's uh
that's kind of the goal with with the
questions that you haven't heard before
is that you don't have a whole lot of
time where did you get the storytelling
if you had to guess
certainly i mean having spent a decent
amount of time in ireland i mean there's
a an incredible tradition
maybe there is something in your code so
to speak but is there another
explanation or another source or
inspiration it is and it's that two of
my cousins on my mom's side started an
improv comedy group
when they were like maybe in college or
so in la and
they were like my idols
stephen connell who's now professional
poet actor writer
and joseph pizzani and they would just
put on these like incredible shows in
the driveway at our family's
annual clambake and call up volunteers
and stuff and just watching the way
their minds worked in connecting the
dots and making everyone laugh and
making it participatory and no one ever
got made fun of in a cruel way ever it
was just we're all in this sort of
absurdity creation together
and that was all our dinner table
conversations were like telling crazies
to listen to them tell crazy stories so
i never aspired to be an actor and as
you know i'm not really interested in
being on video even at all
so i think for me it was just i really
looked up to them and i was just so
impressed with what they could pull out
of thin air and how they could turn
something that seemed so mundane into
the most
delightful and fascinating tale
let's go back to scuba diving for a
second
and the reason i bring it up is because
breathing underwater is cool
because breathing underwater is
[ __ ] rad point one
but point two is that i've seen
transformations in people
where they they have this binary switch
of sorts where they go from
being vaguely interested in marine
biology or the ocean
and they have their first experience
with either snorkeling or scuba in a
vibrant
environment
and something just switches and the way
they relate to
life underwater and the ocean itself
changes
my question for you is are you speaking
from experience
i am speaking from experience so scuba
diving and snorkeling are are two of my
favorite experiences and activities in
the world and
when people talk about colonizing mars
or they talk about psychedelic
experiences and they're like oh probably
never going to have either of those i
just say go
snorkeling or scuba diving do not
trample all the core don't touch
anything
don't touch anything
but
for me it was these were life-changing
experiences and
i'm wondering
if there is any equivalent you have seen
within
discussions around climate or the
subject matter of climate like is there
some experience that people can have
that you have seen or heard of that
flips a switch
and there's a before and after not in a
positive way like that
what you've described is this like awe
and delight
that you can experience when you're
immersed in this
underwater world
the perspective that you gain when you
realize that there's a whole bunch of
stuff that is not about humans and we're
not even supposed to be there
and the way that those marine ecosystems
you can like see the food web in front
of you you can see who's eating who and
like how it's all connected in this
really
dynamic and immediate way
and the thing with climate is it's this
sort of
slow-moving disaster in a sense i mean
it's moving much more quickly than
people had ever thought that it would
every time we read a new report it's
like oh it's actually worse and faster
you know it's never like no big deal
just kidding
and so the thing that
i've seen flip the switch is
natural disasters which is a term i
don't use anymore i call them like
just disasters or extreme weather events
or something like that because they're
not natural anymore this is not
nature as it was intended to be
and so people who experience wildfires
or hurricanes and other sorts of
disasters i think
often have this kind of like
oh [ __ ]
i'm not safe from this you're not safe
from this
for so long it felt like the media was
portraying
climate change something that would
affect like
poor
probably brown people in some faraway
island
and so
americans were
if you read the news sort of insulated
from thinking that this would ever
really come home to roost for us
and in the last few years i think it's
become clear that we're not safe
and wealthier people are
actively working on ways to protect
themselves and their families from the
impacts of the climate crisis but even
they will not be able to hide from that
because they still need to get their
food from somewhere and their medical
treatment from somewhere and we are all
connected
so
i don't know i wish i had a more fun
answer but i think the only equivalent
that i can think of is
you know it's more similar to
experiencing
marine life is the understanding that
species are going extinct because of
this too
these magnificent things that have been
on the planet for
millennia
have no place to live anymore right if
you think about temperature range and
a mountain
and you think okay well they can't
sustain temperatures over a certain
amount so species are moving up and up
and up the mountain but when you get to
the top of the mountain there's no
there's no foliage there's no you're
above the tree line the trees haven't
grown there yet there's no soil there
and there's nowhere else to go there's
no further up to go to get away from the
heat and the same with coral reefs
corals can't get up and move and there's
nowhere
nowhere to go and so we have fish who
are literally
migrating towards the poles to try to
stay cool
and all of these changes are so
dramatic and happening
right before our eyes in our lifetimes
this is not something that's playing out
over generations this is something
that's playing out over years
is really shocking and so for people who
have
a specific
love of nature over time whether it's as
a bird watcher and noticing what birds
are missing or that the birds are coming
at very different times or if you're a
gardener and realize that the first
frost
comes much later and springtime is
changing to change when you plant things
for people who have
a more day-to-day intimate relationship
with any sort of
um species or ecosystem i think
there's sort of a persistent low-level
heartache
about going through the world and seeing
the things that you care about
be so threatened and and these things
start to crumble
what i would love to do as a thought
exercise
okay
is to
play with the idea of
certain
experiences or
struggling i totally failed to tell you
why my parents are the coolest
i mean my parents were like the
proto-hipsters so my dad was living in
fort greene brooklyn when it was like
super rough and he was a student at
pratt it's like art architecture school
and my mom was living in harlem and they
would ride their bicycles and like meet
in central park and like hang out and
they would like play the flute together
and like make homemade pickles and they
had like a whole vegetable garden in the
back of the brownstone they
they got in fort greene back when
brownstones were like 30 something
thousand dollars and like they had like
the whole scenario
sorted and then i came along and was
just like sort of i ruined everything i
ruined all their activities
wow they were hipsters before it was
cool yeah that's amazing it was very
cool so we had like you know they were
playing tennis while wearing white bell
bottoms i mean like the whole thing was
impeccable
and here i am just trying to you know
not let him down
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
helium10 helium1010
is an all-in-one software suite designed
to help entrepreneurs launch manage and
scale profitable e-commerce businesses
on amazon as well as on walmart.com so
whether you're an entrepreneur who wants
to start a business on your own terms or
you want to scale your existing
ecommerce operations helium 10 can help
they process more than 2 billion data
points daily that's a lot of data have a
robust 450 plus million asin database
and provide at a glance analytics like
seasonal trends for products profit
estimates and more i did a bunch of
vetting on these guys with help from all
of you actually
looking for recommendations how much you
would recommend them and i've been very
impressed with the feedback i've seen on
social media from their community of one
million plus users so they cleared the
hurdle and here they are you'll be able
to tap into amazon's existing customer
base product demand and shipping
infrastructure to launch your business
and just as a reminder amazon will
handle all shipping and returns for you
join more than 1 million helium 10 users
worldwide by signing up for a free
account at helium10.com
tim
that is helium10.com
tim sign up for free at h e l i u m
one zero dot com slash tim
let's come back to
your last
answer prior to the pickles and the
flute the flute i wanna
in the basement of our house
yeah and a dark room the whole shebang
so if we look at for a second not as as
fun to discuss but for lack of a better
way to
describe it say
scaring people into action
versus or in combination with inspiring
people into action i'd love to
explore this a little bit
because i think both
obviously can work but if i think about
for instance
some of the things that i've been
involved with whether that's really
interested in in trophic cascade both as
it relates to say sharks
and also
yeah gray wolves so i've been involved
with
a number of do you want to define
trophic cascade for your listeners oh i
think you're gonna be better at doing
that um so so we'll get there we'll get
there in a second we'll get there in a
second and i want you to do it because i
will screw it up and actually one of the
oh god i'm gonna take us all over the
place okay before we get any further
well actually let me just finish my my
little quick piece this is to say that
the shark
component and my introduction to trophic
cascade came about because of a shark
tagging trip that i went on and
then
on the on the wolf side there was a
similar experience that
as you mentioned canon does happen to
people
made me very interested in other
examples of terrific cascade and also
the sort of plight of animals that
become political
targets or political symbols and
there were positive experiences
certainly with
a lot of
terrible stories in the ether around
both of them but ultimately it was kind
of all in wonder that that brought me
into both of those
and
similarly i've seen so i've been very
heavily involved with science related to
psychedelic compounds at johns hopkins
and other places and what has happened
in the last handful of years are many
people i never would have suspected have
become involved with conservation in
south america
through great nonprofits like the amazon
conservation team and others but it
began with first-hand experience with
say some of these displaced
and
indigenous groups in south america do
you think there are
other ways to introduce people
to the
ecosystem that includes
climate change to make them
beneficial proactive participants
that include sort of awe and wonder in
in ways that i haven't described it's a
very long-winded question but i've never
asked it before
i'm with you i think like fear and
anxiety and really
unpleasant news is not terribly
motivating for most people
it is for some for me i actually don't
that often think about the details of
how
bad the scientific projections are and
exactly what's happening to ecosystems
i focus almost entirely on solutions
my perspective is like it's as bad as we
thought and actually worse it's all
happening fast
and then i immediately pivot to what are
we going to do about it like what can i
do to help and i think the thing that's
really interesting to me and actually
super inspiring is that we basically
have all the solutions we need
we know how to transition to 100
renewable energy
we know how to farm in regenerative ways
that restore carbon to the soil instead
of emitting it right we know how to
transform public transit in cities
we know how to compost food we already
know how to do all this stuff we know
how to make buildings more efficient
we know how to improve manufacturing
processes it's just a matter of how fast
we're going to do this and whether
people will get out of their own ways
and
be able to forsake the self-interest
whether that's money or power and just
get this [ __ ] done
and to me that is the thing that gets me
out of bed i'm like how are we gonna get
this [ __ ] done
because we can like because it is a
possibility because we have this
wide range of possible futures still
available to us and i want to be part of
making sure we get the best one
and so the things that i get excited
about i think many people could and will
get more excited about as media starts
to shift from problem to solutions
is
that coastal ecosystems like wetlands
and mangroves
can absorb five times more carbon than a
forest on land let's protect and restore
those let's think about farming oysters
and seaweed in the ocean that absorbs a
lot of carbon and is like a super
low footprint source of food i don't
know you probably have a take on whether
those are good things to eat but they're
super sustainable i'll tell you that
part many americans are iodine deficient
we're gonna come back to that we're
coming back to that and you know some
people get really excited about the
technology figuring out how we're gonna
go from these like clunky solar panels
to solar panels that are just like
regular roof tiles or how we're going to
sort of shift
our food systems to accommodate for
these things what is the role of
technology what is the role of culture
what is the role of politics some people
just like love getting out of bed in the
morning and harassing politicians into
doing better on climate policy and like
i'm glad that that that floats your boat
and so i think
it can be very exciting to consider
how to put your
interests passions superpowers to work
towards specific climate solutions and
we don't have to do all of them like
everyone just has to do something and
the solutions are really cool like
offshore wind turbines powering the 40
of americans who live in coastal
counties that would be great
let's get it going and so
i guess if you think only about the
problem then of course it's a bummer
and i sort of fell into that trap when
you asked me the question in its
previous framing
but when you think about the solutions
there's like no limit to the sources of
inspiration and places to look and
things you'd be like oh
i want that i want to help with that i
want to support that i want to like fund
that i want to
innovate
the 2.0 version of that all right we're
going to play another game the guessing
game okay so i mentioned that i listened
to
many many episodes which was your
favorite
which was your least favorite
we're going to get to both okay
so i have
shared a few episodes with my audience
that's nice
through my newsletter which goes out to
a few million people and
no big deal but the it's
just as a side note i mean it's the
if you want to
push to direct action having direct
contact with your subscribers is very
helpful to anyone out there who's
determining where they should focus on
growing an audience
the question i have for you is which
episodes do you think i chose can you
can you possibly guess
for what best and worst favorite at
least
let's go with the ones i shared so i
wouldn't have shared i wouldn't share
okay
yeah yep
i kind of know your vibe but like not
really um
yeah
i'll give you a just a helpful tip is
that my audience
spans the political spectrum so i well
you just sort of gave it away
okay did i well tell me well what i was
gonna say before you gave me this hint
was the ones on kelp are actually really
interesting because they have this like
sort of like health and wellness and
food angle and like super creative
entrepreneurship piece so i thought you
might have been and they're kind of fun
too
so i thought you might have shared that
but it's a two-parter and so that's like
a little less shareable
that is an excellent guess and you are
correct and this care so
what is this guy's name because the
story about him
a fisherman
living in a tent on the side of a golf
course selling lsd to his fellow
students and this is the guy this is the
just the story
yeah so
getting laid left right and center yeah
yeah i know he's so so the the entire
thing
as a story was and
from the perspective of storytelling
was so riveting that even if someone
said i don't buy climate change
it's still something they would listen
to yeah right and that's why i chose
that was the first episode that i shared
actually and i just thought from a human
interest perspective from a solutions
perspective
from a
capitalist perspective
even though that's the dirty word in
some circles
from an enlightened self-interest
perspective maybe we could say
there are so many entry points on this
episode and it's funny also right it's
the humor and that's something i really
appreciated about
and still do but appreciated about how
you engaged with the podcast and part of
why i kept listening to it was using
humor when possible because this [ __ ]
can be so dark
but that that is the first episode that
i shared
that's a very good
i have a crush on seaweed and bren smith
the fisherman who's now an ocean farmer
is a wonderful human being and i love
his organization green wave which is
training
people to become ocean farmers
and you know doing all this great work
it i'm so enamored with the whole thing
that i joined their board and i'm like
saying no to everyone constantly
so that's how big a fan i am of that
work so it was really great to have him
on the show
do you recall the name of the episode or
how people would find that episode
because it's just
an incredible
story with very colorful characters
involved
what what should people google if they
want to find that up help farming for
the climate
yep so kelp farming for the climate
what i did in my newsletter
is i
renamed the link
so ah so that it wasn't for the climate
that's right uh-huh because the episode
will get there yeah yeah but i didn't
want to
would you name it i didn't want
that is a great
question let me see if i can find it
this might take a minute
so the other episode i thought once you
gave me that
hot tip was that you chose the one where
we
discussed how
to have conversations about
climate change with climate science
deniers
the trying to talk to family about
climate change question mark here's how
episode
i actually
i did not share that one that but i i've
not heard that episode either
a former republican congressman and his
son
talking about how their perspectives on
climate have evolved and how the sun and
his sisters played a big role in
shifting his father's perspective and
how how they're working on
with republicans on trying to get
climate policy and um sort of awareness
past because it doesn't need to be a
partisan issue like we can all care
about
maintaining a habitable planet
so here's here's what i put in my
newsletter so the newsletter is called
five bullet friday and it's just the
five kind of coolest most interesting
things i've come across or experimented
with that week and this is podcast
episode i'm listening to from cod
fishing to kelp farming i put in
parentheses my title and then with dr
elizabeth johnson and alex bloomberg
and here's what i wrote for many reasons
i'm considering investing heavily in
aquaculture so i've been doing a deep
dive pun intended into the subject
and then we can deconstruct why i wrote
it this way this episode is incredibly
smart incredibly helpful and incredibly
hilarious i didn't expect the characters
involved and kept bursting out laughing
at the gym this morning i looked like a
crazy person but kept on listening
whether you want an investing advantage
or simply great stories this episode is
really worth the time and if you'd like
to learn storytelling and podcasting
tips from one of the co-hosts alex
bloomberg you can find my 2015 interview
with him here so the reason i positioned
it this way and the reason i renamed the
title is because i wanted as
as large a funnel at the top
of people who would click play on this
episode as possible so that's why i
positioned it the way that i did
i'm glad you like our corny jokes
and i'm very surprised that so many of
them made the cuts
are you sure i was astonished that uh
what was what was the kelp farmer's name
again brent smith bran with no t b-r-e-n
b-r-e-n okay so i was surprised you kept
in everything he said related to the d10
which you alluded to because he was like
yeah if you really want to get a lot of
ass in college turns out
living in a tent by the golf course is
the way to do it yeah it was it was just
it was it was i could not have predicted
that that would be the way but you know
okay what do you think my
what do you think my
least favorite
episodes
might be oh
you went plural least favorite well well
i wanna i wanna but i wanna i'm gonna
provide a lens though and this is not
gonna be surprising
not least favorite to personally listen
to my
those
those
least likely to share least likely to
share um black lives matter in the
climate
i need to really double re-title that
one
yeah you're close but it's it's not
exactly that it's any episode that had
a mixture of many
causes or multiple causes
not because they don't matter not
because they aren't important but
because i felt like it was
if i'm trying to use a trojan horse
approach to get the funnel to be as
large as possible for clicking i didn't
want
in the beginning later things can can be
different but i i wanted to provide
sort of single points of action if that
makes any sense so not the one titled
environmentalist drag queen patty gonia
says the outdoors is for everyone
that's right not the one that says we
can't solve the climate crisis without
gender equality we'll prove it to you
so if there were episodes that laid out
in the call to action sort of a clear
sequence or in the narrative clear
sequence
then i would be open to sharing it if it
felt to me like
and hopefully this doesn't come across
terribly but
if i felt like for the listener who is
not
who feels like the climate
acting
in some proactive way
with respect to climate change is futile
if that's how they're coming into it
like i don't think there's really
anything i can do
if they're already demoralized about
that if i felt like an episode might
kind of look like the back of a car in
like berkeley california with multiple
bumper stickers that they wouldn't know
how to put in any order or make any
sense and therefore they would just opt
out then
i would be less inclined to share it
doesn't mean they're not important
episodes which was your favorite episode
that you
didn't share because of that reason
i'll give an example of one i liked but
then also had some issues with
i thought the
episode related to and you're gonna have
more of the specifics here but the i
guess you would say activists within
amazon
i thought that was a really interesting
episode
that
had a couple of points in
the dialogue that veered into
a number of different
areas that made it hard for me to be
totally sympathetic to some of the
protagonists in
the episode but i did find
that very interesting from the
perspective of
the incredible leverage you can get if
you are able to successfully catalyze
action within
enormous companies especially those with
large
carbon footprints side note did british
petroleum actually create the term
carbon footprint they definitely
popularized it and like trade upon it
and try to make it seem like this whole
thing is our fault
i'm not sure if they actually coined the
term yeah but shifting
creating online calculators to sort of
shift the onus to the individual it's
it's it's brilliant and like i mean it
really is yeah yeah i mean it's kind of
like the best of the worst sort of words
that work
frank lunt's type of you know death tax
you know yeah we need
more of these like
linguistic jiu-jitsu happening on the
side of climate solutions yes
and you know i noticed that with uh some
of your sponsors on the show also and i
was like oh that's quite clever
i think it was i don't even know who
they were
i don't think that well there was there
was i want to say and again god all
right this is really going down
here
faulty memory at work but i think it was
i want to say fidelity or some
investment firm that offered the ability
to invest in
for lack of a better term climate
friendly or uh climate solution focused
do not personally endorse
no no right but i noticed i noticed that
instead of saying they said the green
transition and i was like that's an
interesting way of phrasing it
that's a very interesting way of
phrasing it because the language matters
the word i've been using a lot is
transformation
because that's i feel like the
most
embraceable word i can think of
that indicates just how much things have
to change we're not talking about
tweaking
little things tweaks and policy tweaks
and behavior tweaks and corporate
practices we're talking about
transforming our energy system food
system transportation manufacturing
buildings all of it and when you think
about
the climate challenge in those terms
there is a place for everybody in
working towards these solutions in
figuring out this green transition or
this transformation because no matter
where you work your company needs to be
a part of this no matter where you live
your community needs to be prepared for
this no matter what skills you have
believe me they are necessary and so i
think of that as that the word
transformation both is
appropriate to the scale of what needs
to happen but also
a bit more
welcoming because it implies that we can
still sort of shape the future that we
want which is true
let's talk about transformation and
large scale broad spectrum
transformation because the the scale of
that i can imagine intimidating a lot of
people and them saying you know what i'm
going to be a drop in the ocean
pun intended and it's just not going to
what am i going to do really like am i
going to replace my straws and
make a difference i don't think i can do
anything for those people and i know
you've spoken about this and you've
spoken about in the podcast as well
but how do you suggest people think
about
where they might fit in and the venn
diagram
comes to mind yeah
what do you recommend to people are
saying you know i would love to do
something realistically i don't i can't
make this my full-time job like what
would you have me do how would you
suggest i even think about it i would
say don't think about it as a side thing
think about how this is part of your
life already
and so i think often people think i want
to help on some environment thing
they're like do i go volunteer for a
nonprofit do i quit my job and like go
do this entirely other thing
when the answer is often
change your company
change your sports team change your
church figure out how to way to put have
the things you're already a part of
where you already have influence and
leverage
change those things
as opposed to trying to like
do some entirely new thing that you have
no networking or or power in this idea
of power mapping of figuring out where
you actually have the ability to make
change i think is a really important
step
and this sort of
i think in many ways the environmental
movement had like a real problem
initially because it was asking everyone
to do the same thing we still fall into
this trap right like everybody
spread the word everybody march everyone
donate everyone vote and we should do
all those things of course but if you
and i were both doing the same exact
thing to contribute to climate solutions
that would be a total waste of both of
our time right like we should do the
things we're good at
and so the way that i think about it and
we sort of went into this
sort of debate between individual
behavior change where it does all add up
if we all change our diets if we all
change our transportation if we all
change our electricity that does add up
to something but they're counting on
individuals to change things is that
need whole systems to change i don't get
to choose where my electricity comes
from when i turn on my lights in this
apartment building per se
so we need to make the system make other
things possible
in terms of energy for example
so
we did this whole episode called is
your carbon footprint bs talking about
this debate between
i hoped you would like that one this
debate between two siblings for one was
like individual actions matter and the
other one was like no only this big
level systems change stuff matters and
the answer that we landed on is
that your individual actions matter in
so much as they contribute to larger
scale change and the way that i think
about everyone finding their sort of
like bespoke role in climate solutions
is this
venn diagram of just three circles
and the first one is what are you good
at
what superpowers what skills are you
bringing to the table your network your
resources what you got
and then the next circle would be what
part of this transformation do you want
to work on right are you really excited
about
seaweed are you really excited about
offshore wind farms are you really
excited about bike lanes or composting
or political change or cultural shifts
like whatever is the piece like there
are so many pieces to this puzzle and no
one can do them all so just which ones
are you picking
and then the third circle is what brings
you joy so what gets you out of bed in
the morning because so often people
assume that this work has to be
miserable and some sort of slog
but this is the work of our lifetimes
and it's like this whole transformation
so if we could pick between doing
anything and transforming any sector
like pick something that that you can
keep working on for a while that that
will energize you
and you want to bring other people in
and so finding our way to the epicenter
each of us of our personal
version of that venn diagram can be
really powerful so
for example i as a marine biologist and
a kid who grew up in brooklyn a coastal
city and a policy nerd who loves
thinking about design
i co-founded a think tank for the future
of coastal cities because i was like
this is what i'm good about and know
about and care about i'm excited about
so let's just mash all that up together
and see like how we can help coastal
cities
change their policies in order to adapt
to the climate changes that are coming
and my friend boris was like well i'm
should we just go to more marches i
brought him to a climate protest he's
like do we just do this again next week
was like no go change your company like
you're an executive at betterment and
nine months later he launched their
sustainable investing fund
which is much more power i don't care if
he ever goes to a march again because
that doesn't matter because he has this
like much greater ability to make change
where he already is
so what are you going to do tim
tell us about your venn diagram
[Music]
well
[Music]
i will answer that the
the the energize you part i just want to
underscore because i think it is so
totally so so so important and
much like
the in the podcast world there's like
this elephant graveyard of three episode
podcasts because people choose something
at the outset
that is too complex not interesting
enough to them not energizing and then
they quit right so
i really think that energized peace is
is huge and enjoy like we can find joy
in our work
especially if it's like volunteer work
like pick a fun one yeah
so for me part of the reason i've been
looking forward to this conversation
well there are many reasons i've been
looking for this conversation including
the sass mostly because i played hard to
get
mostly because she played hard to get
this is very true very very very true
uh
so i don't do it in dating but
apparently i do it with podcast invites
you know and it works and it works so
for me
if i'm getting all vulnerable and stuff
right now the last two years
have been very
difficult for me from the perspective of
existential distress and just
disappointment in
humanity in general that's why when
people are like oh what are you doing
for philanthropy i'm like i'm not sure
that's the right word because like
phil anthro like anthropology i don't
actually like humans that much
uh
and humans are consistently
disappointing aren't they
yeah and so the last two years i've just
been like we're [ __ ] i just i don't
see how we write this [ __ ] but like how
[ __ ] do you want to be
well
hold on
so it's like in my mind i'm thinking
well it's like if kovid this clear and
present danger that is literally killing
people right in front of us
can't get
political leaders to coordinate or
cooperate
how are we going to handle
this like iceberg that we're heading
towards that is you know on the range of
possibly decades away and i i understand
it's not a
a switch that gets flipped but yeah it's
here
yeah it's here and i was just like god
you know maybe i should just uh you know
pick up pottery
uh take some watercolor classes and just
enjoy last cause i think we're
make some pickles and
what i think
got me
well i wasn't totally on the bench right
i was listening to things like your
podcast i've been reading books i've
read drawdown i would actually love your
thoughts on that because they
they rank and i don't know if their
algorithm or their method is
scientifically credible i just don't
know but that's what it was given to me
it's very good and their new version the
drawdown review available for free
online i can share the link with you is
wonderful and like the graphic design
makes everything super clear
okay i'll tie this in then because i
went through drawdown i paid particular
attention to the back and the appendices
and i looked at where my strengths and
enthusiasm might overlap and i was like
okay i see that refrigerants is really
really high
yeah but i just i don't know anything
about refrigerants it doesn't excite me
i don't have any particular knowledge or
network related to refrigerants but
there were somewhere i was like okay i
could actually see
becoming involved in say aquaculture
and
spoke to
a number of people i won't mention by
name but who are very very some of the
smartest technologists in the world who
i know right and they they mentioned
that they thought some of the most
promising interventions were ocean-based
and
talked about different organizations and
companies you know climb works and
carbon removal
things like charm industrial which i
find super super super interesting
and a name that we chatted about before
we started recording chris saka also got
me
very interested in looking at
sort of solutions
focused obviously market driven
technologies that might play a role and
the reason that got me excited is not
because i'm a techno optimist who's like
we can [ __ ] up everything because
you know there will be this like uh
deus ex machina like god out of the sky
who will save us with some new
technology i don't really endorse that
kind of approach but
the idea that you could align just the
most cold-blooded
capitalist animal
to do the right thing in self-interest
for the collective does that make sense
was very exciting a lot of money to be
made in green energy in
in food system shifts in transportation
holiday yeah
yeah yeah huge and so that got me very
excited
and you might laugh at me but another
thing that got me
off the bench was
the recent breakthroughs in fusion
technologies and i know the joke is like
fusion's always 30 years away
but
looking at it more closely i was like
you know what
man there are so many ways this this
might not work
and so many
challenges but if it does
this could be extremely extremely
i mean exponentially
more effective than many of these these
other technologies that are that are
being brought to bear on the problem not
to say that's the only option right
because i think that's a hail mary or
some people view it as a hail mary but
it was
it was fusion that got me really excited
and you know i'm looking at a text from
a friend of mine he's saying you know
advanced geothermal ocean wind looked
very promising
so you mentioned the uh
i'm not sure the phrasing you used but
the the ocean wind i think is very short
offshore wind and
these are also places where so i'll give
you just a quick example
that maps for me in my mind so i've
spent
many years now and thousands of hours on
psychedelic science and medicine and
therapeutics and so on i've i made a
decision very early on not to invest in
any for-profit companies because i
wanted to preserve my ability to kind of
critique and comment on the space and to
be viewed as unbiased so
that was my decision but i did a lot of
fundraising and i've raised
certainly i'd be in the top i'd say
three people who've raised money in the
space
but as soon as a few for-profit
companies
began to show promise and went public
um for better and for worse a lot of the
people who were donating to the
non-profits completely abandoned it and
went to for-profit and i think there are
issues with that related to ip and
otherwise
but
i do think that
just based on the number of limited
partners meaning investors and so on who
have started to plow money into some of
these technologies we're talking about
that got me
excited because you could finally
in my mind sort of align in an exciting
way
individual self-interest even if they
don't give a [ __ ] about
the environment
which
preferably they would but even if they
don't with sort of collective betterment
so what am i going to do i'm going to
interview people like you i'm going to
have uh entrepreneurs on the podcast who
are and i want to make this really clear
putting climate aside putting all of
that aside
really incredible
thinkers and entrepreneurs and builders
at the end of the day like they can
stand on their own two feet from that
perspective so their story is
interesting much like bren
even if you take
sort of climate out of it or any
politics out of it
and i'll be investing right like i'm
investing i've done a lot of early stage
investing and i've started in the last
six to 12 months especially
putting i would say probably at this
point like the majority of my
investing dollars into some of these
startups i love it
so that's what i'm gonna do
and you know we'll see where it goes but
i'm into it i think the highlighting
people doing
the work is interesting because
in many cases it's so surprising because
people don't think about the full
spectrum of ways you can be a part of a
solution so showing like oh no you can
be like a tycoon and do this you can be
a tech nerd and do this you can be a
technologist and do this you can be
a health nut and do this like whatever
is your thing we need you and i think
that's really exciting that's actually
the same approach
that we took with the anthology that i
co-edited all we can save which is this
collection of 40 or so essays by
women leading on climate work and to see
side by side
an essay by a woman who led the beyond
coal campaign at the sierra club which
has effectively shut down over 300
coal-fired power plants in the u.s in
the last decade this is not peanuts this
is the transformation right to that
side-by-side with a supermodel writing
about how the fashion industry is part
of the problem and an artist writing
about how she's part of the solution and
a landscape architect talking about how
we're going to protect coastal cities by
replanting more oysters and thinking
about how we design our coastlines
differently right having a farmer tell
the stories of how they've shifted their
practices and are training the next
generation
all of these are super interesting and
like i haven't said climate once right
like it's about this like cool work that
people are doing that is contributing to
the changes that we need to see and
honestly it's stuff that would need to
happen even if climate change weren't a
problem because burning coal is really
bad for our health and it's bad for the
planet even if it didn't change the
climate
because fast fashion is really dangerous
for
for people and the planet in other ways
it's toxic and bad for workers right
like it's not a good thing anyway eating
industrial food pool of pesticides is
not good for us anyway and it's not good
for the planet or the climate and so
i think
you're right that for so many of the
solutions that we have they are better
jobs they result in cleaner water
cleaner air things are just more
beautiful and green and we can still
make plenty of money it's just a better
world full stop
on all these different levels and so you
can actually in many cases
take climate out of the equation because
fossil fuels are bad for our health
right they are so bad for maternal
health right it is really dangerous for
babies to be exposed to all these toxins
we know that there's like associated
with like birth weight and birth defects
and all of these other problems
not to mention what's happening in coal
mining communities with public health
and black lung and all of these things
and the pollution of the waterways and
the loss of ecosystems so i think
yeah sure if you want to do this for
another reason besides the climate
that's fine with me we need to get it
done
not to mention fertility overall it's
just terrifying to see yeah with uh not
sure what you would call them
microplastics and so i mean it's uh
terrifying people people should watch uh
children of men as a preview oh i
haven't seen that yeah oh yeah it's
brutal it's worth checking out it's
pretty dystopian but it's not um it's
not improbable have you seen the new
film don't look up
no
what's that adam mckay directed at this
new film he directed like i don't know
uh vice and you were done saturday night
live and he's a comedy writer
and it stars leonardo dicaprio and
jennifer lawrence
um and all these other it's star-studded
meryl streep and tyler perry and
all these folks and it's basically like
a satire a parable where this comet is
coming to hit the earth
and
and we sort of ignore it
and there's a whole campaign that says
don't look up
you know
and like meryl streep plays the
president and she's more worried about
getting votes than about like deflecting
this comet from like ruining all life on
earth and some technologist is like wait
we could just mine the comet like let's
not deflect it and all of this stuff
right it is this like
anxiety-inducing for anyone who's been
trying to communicate on climate for
years
piece of cinema and the point was to
spark more conversation on climate and
do it in a way that uses humor so when
you said you appreciated how to save a
planet which you know the podcast i
co-created
because
it was funny at least to you
i really appreciated that because i
think we need more climate media that is
deploying humor because humor
quantitatively we know is a way to like
have people
open their minds to new ideas right when
you're laughing you're not fighting
you're you're able to listen it helps
you let your guard down it helps you
like be in community with people in a
different way
so i actually just released an op-ed
today co-authored with the director the
title is why our secret weapon against
the climate crisis could be humor oh
amazing so i'll read that yeah in the
guardian
uh we will link to that in the show
notes as well so let me uh
just
kind of brain vomit on you for a second
and then i'd love to
and then i'd love to love to get your
your perspective so and again i i don't
mean to draw this comparison constantly
but there are some parallels so in the
case of
psychedelic science and therapeutics
let's just say mdma assisted
psychotherapy for ptsd or sulciben for
let's just say
end of life anxiety in terminal cancer
patients both real research examples and
both are in phase three trials or i have
just completed facebook trials they're
very close to the kind of regulatory
finish line per se and the data look
very very very good
the
tip of the spear that has ended up
becoming incredibly
strategically important for all of these
not just
cultural narrative changes but political
changes and regulatory changes
has been
focusing on the veteran populations who
suffer from ptsd because the veterans
have
political immunity in the sense that
neither side republican nor democrat can
come out and say [ __ ] the vet it just it
would be incredibly politically
damaging while still passing policies
that essentially do that
yeah right exactly but nonetheless like
that has become a
key
piece of the puzzle
for allowing both sides to cooperate in
any fashion
and and i that's another reason why
although there are a lot of kind of
anti-business anti-capitalist
folks on the left but
nonetheless
i think most people recognize that
capitalism is kind of the best of the
worst options that we have
i viewed some of the for-profit
solutions as one bridge potentially
are there other ways you think to get
people to cooperate
who are on opposite sides of the
political spectrum are there other
bridges or other tricks anything the one
that comes to mind because you use this
example of veterans is
the immense risk that our dependence on
fossil fuels places on our armed forces
our military
we are literally fighting wars for oil
we would not have to do that we would
all those lives would be saved if we
were just using sunshine and wind
instead or geothermal or whatever
magical fusion thing you think will
happen soon
um well hold on don't put words in my
mouth
renewable energies
and i think
we don't understand that like you know
military convoys like so many of them
are actually just transporting fuel for
military operations and that's what's
getting bombed right like it is putting
our soldiers at risk this dependence
it is creating wars in places
where the weather patterns have changed
so dramatically that there is feminine
that leads to unrest that leads to
violence that leads to the united states
getting involved right like this is a
national security issue this is the
safety of our military issue and so in
some senses the military has the
foresight to say like climate change is
absolutely happening how are we going to
plan for this
they are taking steps to think through
a lot of those practicalities but this
is it is extremely disrespectful of our
troops
to be putting people in harm's way for
reasons that don't exist like we just do
not have to live this way on this planet
and so i i wish that people would talk a
little bit more about that
and it's the same for thinking about our
naval bases all on the coast all at risk
of sea level rise and storms we have you
know in norfolk virginia the big base
there access is cut off during high
rains the street floods because of sea
level rise right and so that is
absolutely a national security and
safety issue there's a lot of stuff on
that side that i wish
more people would
appreciate if we're going to say support
our troops that means we have to deal
with climate change i think
on the other side
just the joy of nature like the ability
to go for a hike the ability to enjoy
springtime the ability to be outside in
the summer and not melt
the ability to go skiing the ability to
go scuba diving on a coral reef all
these pleasures that exist because
nature has been relatively stable for a
long time like i would love to go skiing
this winter in driving distance of new
york city but not looking really good
right now for snow
and so thinking about it from not just
self-interest or financial gain which
there are plenty of arguments for that
as well but thinking about it from the
things that we love to do
in the world being all at risk i mean
coffee chocolate wine all of this is
getting turned upside down by the
changes in our climate that we can't
grow these things as well anymore
wildfires in napa obviously no good for
many reasons
so i think we could be a bit more
hedonistic about why we should do
something to preserve our our dionysian
pleasures in the world
yeah if you don't want i mean i was
watching a program on wine production
and how that has shifted
and how things are being grown in the uk
that you know 50 years ago couldn't have
been grown in the uk
and i don't know somebody had mentioned
this to me i didn't fact check it but
that a lot of
lobster harvesting is moving to canada
due to climate lobster used to be very
common in long island sound no longer
here and starting to move out of maine
and even further north into nova scotia
let me ask you a question about your
episodes okay of the podcast
because i gave my best shot but you've
certainly listened to more episodes than
i have
which episodes which episodes i do
listen to them all after and i like do a
game tape thing i'm like how could i
have done that better how could that
joke of landing i do oh are you serious
absolutely oh all right everyone is
illegal
all the better since you're doing these
post game analyses to ask the question i
wanted to ask which is
which episodes
worked the best and which would you have
done
differently
to have them work better and by work
you're in a unique position
to speak to working because you always
had a call to action
so so so i suppose another way to phrase
this would be which episodes have had
the biggest impact and which would you
have done differently to have them
have a greater impact if you could maybe
give an example of each this is a
question i would love to be able to
answer quantitatively but i can't i
don't think there's like robust tracking
of like who's clicking what and taking
what actions afterwards i sort of like
wanted there to be a whole dashboard
built out and the whole thing i i did
not get my wish
and i also had uh myself taken off the
the email distribution for all incoming
listener mail because it was just too
much
so i don't even have sort of like a firm
qualitative grasp after the first few
episodes
but i think
for a bunch of episodes we had the same
call to action which was
call your members of congress
because
this is our chance to pass federal
climate policy
through the the combination of the
infrastructure bill which did pass and
had some climate measures in it and the
buildback better plan which has like way
more in terms of the energy transition
supporting the shift to electric cars
all sorts of you know infrastructure and
federal related things that we need to
see happen
we encourage people to call their
members of congress and say like we
actually i support this i think we
should have a good climate policy in
america i think we should have a
civilian climate corps that puts
americans to work restoring and
protecting our ecosystems and building
physically this transition
i think we should have offshore wind
energy in this country we've got a lot
of ocean we've got a lot of wind
and and you know i think we should have
a hundred percent clean electricity by
2035 which is the goal we can get there
we got to get it going
and so encouraging people offering
specific talking points this is not
partisan this is just like we need the
federal government to do its part in
jump starting this transition just as
they did with innovating the internet or
funding tesla to get started the
government funds a lot of really
important early stage stuff in r d and
jump starts it so we had a ton of people
calling in which matters because very
few people actually
pick up the phone and call the
representatives
i'm super super wussy about it for some
reason even though i know you can call
after hours and just leave a voicemail i
still get like really nervous
but because so few people call your call
has outsized weight they they have to
log every call from their constituents
if they get 10 calls on anything they're
like what is our position on this and
they have to develop one they have to be
able to answer to people who elected
them
they assume 10 people didn't call who
feel the same way so your voice actually
does have a lot of power in that context
and so seeing people feel like
that actually mattered is a way to
leverage you know
leverage your power as a citizen
and then we also had a lot of people
after the electric car episode that were
like i bought an electric car because
that episode was great
so it sort of like spans the counter
people like i'm eating so much more kelp
now but i think having this sort of
cult action at the end of every episode
whether it's like try out some seaweed
recipes or
call your senator hopefully there's sort
of something for everyone all right i
want to
mention a couple of things and then jump
into some more it's got like a smirk
with that intro that i'm like what are
you going to mention
my smirk i always have a spark this is
why some people this is why half the
internet hates me i'm convinced is i
just have a very punchable face like
people are like what's that [ __ ]
smirk about and i can't erase it
it could be it could be the uh you know
lenin
not as in john lennon but as in the uh
yeah the sort of russian propaganda um
yeah the american history x look that i
can't seem to avoid uh might be a
problem but a couple things i want to
mention just for people listening first
is if you want to see some of the
coolest companies i've come across
anywhere
go to lower carbon capital this is
krisaka and team
you will see some of the craziest
coolest things you can possibly imagine
just
check that out another is to echo what
what you just said the calls really
matter i i have
interviewed arnold schwarzenegger on the
podcast uh once maybe twice and i've
gotten to know his team and i've gotten
to know a number of other lawmakers and
precisely as you said because so few
people call if you get a few dozen
people to call
or a few hundred people to call they
will pay attention and also the question
i have for you is about cultural
pressure and getting to some type of
tipping point with respect to elected
officials and here's the phrasing of the
question
i think
expecting
politicians to do anything that does not
assist them in getting elected or
re-elected is probably
naive in the same way that to expect
most public company ceos to plan 20
years out
is
unrealistic if they're being rewarded
based on quarterly represent
loss to save the planet
right well so right so i think i think i
think just people respond to incentives
so
so my question for you
is what do you think it will take are
there kind of next actions that i or
other people could be thinking about in
the next few years within the next few
years that could help shift that tide to
the point that
politicians actually need to think about
and
take positions
yeah more aggressive positions now sadly
it could be in the opposite direction
also but what can we do to make it
matter more we need to protect voting
rights
the majority of americans understand
that climate change is a massive problem
it's only nine percent of americans who
are full-blown climate science deniers
okay it is we have the largest
percentage of americans ever now who are
like deeply alarmed about the climate
crisis it's about a third
it's not about getting and you know and
then there's like alarm there's concerns
there's like all these different levels
but it's like the vast majority of
americans are like holy [ __ ] climate
change what are we gonna do and so it's
not that we don't have the constituency
for it it's that have you seen the shape
of these ridiculous congressional
districts the way that they're
gerrymandered that they don't actually
reflect communities that they're just
designed to elect a specific party
the voter registration laws the way
they're purging the voter rolls the way
they're requiring all these more forms
of identification so passing the voting
rights act
passing voter protections more generally
is actually a really important step
because our voices can't be heard as
citizens if we can't
elect the people who
share our views because the system is so
skewed
and so that is something people i think
don't think about enough that like
saving the structure of our democracy
of representative democracy of the
electoral process
is actually really critical because
we already do have the numbers but we're
losing because of that
and one of the organizations that i'm
completely enamored with that is doing
work along these lines is called the
environmental voter project and what
they've identified is that there's 10
million 16 million sometimes
environmentalists self-described who
have you know environment as their
number one issue who are already
registered to vote and who do not go to
the polls
that is the lowest hanging fruit right
already registered already care need to
get them out to vote and so i volunteer
with that organization and serve on
their advisory board because we know how
close these elections are they're all
like one percent like a few hundred
people in some cases so getting people
to actually
go and use their right to vote is super
critical
so those are the things that are on my
mind now because they're also like we're
coming up on midterm elections
and making sure that we make it clear to
politicians that we actually we want you
to have a good climate policy platform
we need you to protect your constituents
in every state we're dealing with really
wild extreme weather events from
landslides to wildfires to floods to
droughts to hurricanes to tornadoes out
of nowhere to fire tornadoes i mean
it's crazy
um and so this is not a partisan issue
this is about doing your job and
protecting your constituents but i hear
you that like
if they don't feel that their
re-election is at risk
it doesn't matter
and so we need to protect voting rights
and we also need to think about how
elections are funded
the citizens united supreme court case
that allowed corporations to fund
elections really weakened our democracy
dramatically so like i know sort of a
welfare but like overturned citizens
united would be like a great step to
climate policy in america because we
wouldn't have the chamber of commerce
and all of these fossil fuel companies
and pipeline companies able to literally
pay for elections
which is super dangerous
i can't compete with that so i think
just safeguarding our electoral process
on the campaign finance side and on the
voting rights side are really key
we will
add links to the show notes for
everybody with everything that we're
talking about including those
organizations now when i hear that
it sounds overwhelmingly complex like
there is
next to nothing that i could do
in that sphere as someone who also is i
don't want to say are you okay
but
well you tell me then let's do a deeper
dive then so like what could someone who
is
has an allergic reaction to politics
still do
to assist in something
like i don't know how to deal with your
allergy per se
i don't take an antihistamine and just
[ __ ] jump in
i think it comes down to like choosing
the thing that you care about right like
we can't care about everything and
that's why like the environmental voter
project for me is like easy let's get
people who already care who are already
registered to vote to get to the pulse i
can do that i can host phone banks you
could host a phone bank with me wouldn't
that be a blast
you can tell people to volunteer you
just call your neighbors and be like hey
we need you to vote right like pick the
person with the good climate platform
it'll be very clear probably which
person that is and i think
to think about local elections too often
you know at the presidential level at
the senate level it's a very different
calculus for people who feel very
aligned with a particular political
party but when it comes to city council
which is where your transit and waste
management and recycling and composting
and bike lane and building code and
whatever decisions are getting made in
your city governments you can focus on
those elections it doesn't have to feel
so loaded and partisan it can feel like
we need to get things right where i live
i want to be a part of that and also i
will say local elections you can support
candidates and your dollars go way
further because in a presidential or
senate election you're talking like
millions tens of millions of dollars
local elections often the entire budget
for a campaign is like
10 grand
and so i've hosted fundraisers where
we've been able to like double the
campaign budget of these
local candidates to help them get their
ideas and their platforms out so that
more people will know what they stand
for
to me it makes it feel a lot more
both possible and concrete to think
about local elections and there's an
organization called lead locally that
focuses on local candidates with great
climate platforms so thinking about like
who's running your port authority who's
running your railroad commission who's
running your school board what are our
kids getting taught about how we deal
with these challenges
all of those positions really matter too
because it's at the local level that
these
policies and solutions are often getting
implemented like that's where the rubber
meets the road
all right i'm gonna do a much deeper
dive i'll do some homework
i'll do some homework and uh we'll have
some beers and talk about it okay uh
the
the
do you drink beer
so much gluten no
full of pesticides wheat is like one of
the highest pesticide crops you know
glyphosates super dangerous fish you
mentioned beer before we got started
you're the one who started this whole
thing
i like tequila tequila and gin okay you
get tequila all of mescal will like meet
on the internet
you know we could have some sotol that's
a that's a whole separate thing it's
kind of like a mixture it's anyway we'll
get into it another time but you may all
taste it
all right so the the the question that i
want to ask you is related to a term i
brought up earlier which i think about
it's not the way that everyone thinks
about these things but the minimum
effective dose and what i mean by that
is
what are some small things that people
can do
that
don't require
sacrifices and they may be things that
are not even aware
have the magnitude of impact that they
do and one i wanted to give as an
example right because i think
sometimes people who have causes
try to shame the hell out of people and
ask them to change all of their
behaviors and it just doesn't work right
so i'm always looking for
the gateway drug like what is something
really small that won't get a lot of
pushback for most people and i thought
we would start with an example
which is on the faq
at your website the faq
shrimp
talk about shrimp please because this is
a great example yeah
i will say i appreciate the need for
people to have a place to start but i
also
object to the framing that there's the
way people often ask me the question
which is like what's one simple thing i
can do to like save the planet i'm like
maybe like what's the first thing you
can do
so i think
okay shrimp here's the rundown
let me let me just say one thing before
we move on because i know you got shrimp
covered with your eyes closed um
i feel like if people believe
that they are just getting the first
homework assignment of a never-ending
list it doesn't have to be homework
i'm just saying if that's the way it's
framed if they're like one little thing
isn't good enough they'll be like you
know what then i'm out like if if i
don't
if this is pandora's box that is and i'm
never going to get positive
reinforcement then i'm just not going to
do anything because why wouldn't i do
we're getting positive reinforcement all
right i will be so proud
when you do
that imagine what happens when you do
dead things how proud of you i will be
um i think this is i get it it's just
like it's this human behavior thing and
i i've i've definitely like
grumbled that if i wanted to be useful i
should have gotten a degree in
psychology because this is all about how
people make decisions and what motivates
people and like
i'm not an expert in that but i know
that like if we each do one little thing
we will not solve the entire climate
crisis and like prevent apocalypse right
and so figuring out like that's why the
venn diagram is like what brings you joy
like do that do it more than once you
know so i'm i'm here for the the
delights and the positive reinforcement
and i would say
that one way to make that happen
is to not do it alone
like do this with your homies like do
this with your family do this with your
friends do this with your group text
like find a thing that you all enjoy
doing
and there's a very cool website that
patagonia made full disclosure i'm on
their board
that's called action works and it's what
they call skill based volunteering
and so you can go to the website and
search like buy the things that you're
good at like i'm good at video editing
okay great this non-profit needs help
making a video about installing bike
lanes in the community um or you're good
at event planning and you're like oh
this non-profit's doing a thing like i
could volunteer and help them do that or
oh this other group needs help with
their accounting like they just don't
have that expertise in house and you're
an accountant you can help with that so
i think things like that that feel like
specifically useful
can often keep us going and you're
contributing to something that's bigger
and maybe you like working with those
people maybe they're delightful
and and then we have also things like
shrimp which is for me i will say it's
not just one simple thing and then
you're done yeah it's a way to trick
people into thinking more about these
things yeah that's it right and then
you've opened
the the door so to speak so
shrimp i'll just give my like personal
quick take i read this today and i was
like i was like holy [ __ ] my friend
talked i remember a friend talking about
this and the fact of the matter is like
you know i i have shrimp but it's like i
don't need shrimp i don't like them that
much it's easy for me to avoid in the
same way that i saw like my octopus
teacher and i was like i don't need deed
octopus
in japan and everything like i don't
need octopus you need them alive in the
ocean being charming and weird
yeah so shrimp i keep stumbling uh like
i keep interfering please tell us about
shrimp if there's one seafood you should
probably stop eating it is the most
popular seafood in america which is
shrimp
because there's there's basically two
ways that it gets to your plate and
they're both horrible there's very minor
exceptions but you'll know if you're
part of the exception because you will
be paying a lot of money for these very
special shrimp
but in general shrimp either comes
from
the wild ocean in which case that
there's a a net that's dragged along the
sea floor and shrimp are pretty tiny so
it's a pretty fine mesh net so it's
catching like everything else that's
there and sort of bulldozing
the the seafloor habitat and all of that
stuff that they pull up
most of it just is made sometimes it's
like 10 shrimp
and so the rest is often thrown back
dead or dies because it's coming up from
such depth that it basically gets
its decompression sickness all these
fish
and so the waste associated with that
type of fishing is enormous the habitat
damage is really significant and also
often the labor practices on those boats
are truly horrific
and then on the flip side you can farm
shrimp aquaculture in in coastal ponds
and to do that which is mostly happening
in southeast asia they're bulldozing the
mangroves which are
ecosystems that absorb a lot of carbon
and protect the shorelines from things
like tsunamis after that big tsunami
maybe 10 or 15 years ago places that had
intact mangroves actually did much
better than places that didn't have a
natural barrier left
and so you're bulldozing this ecosystem
which is also the habitat for all the
juvenile fish that you would otherwise
be catching offshore it's their nursery
and you're putting in these
high density ponds of
shrimp and you're feeding them all this
food and all the shrimp are pooping and
then they're all getting diseases and
you're putting antibiotics and like
things to kill lice and all these
chemicals and it's polluting the local
environment and i don't really want to
eat shrimp that's grown that way and
then often in the processing side of
things enslaved people are used to peel
those shrimp if you get like pre-peeled
frozen shrimp from southeast asia i
would not feel good about eating that
for
people or the planet
so that's why i'm like ah let's just
stop with the shrimp unless it's like
oregon trap caught pink shrimp or like
recirculating aquaculture florida shrimp
right like but those are sort of fancy
and you'll know
if that's what you're getting
i know it's a bummer shrimp cocktail
like very iconic but they're also so
easy to order something else yeah let's
move past it
i know eating bugs is cool and high
protein and low impact and whatever but
not really you know as someone who has
eaten a fair number of crickets i take
offense although
interestingly enough if someone has a
shellfish allergy they should also not
eat any insect-based proteins because
the allergy noted is
the same so if you can't eat shrimp
don't don't eat too many arthropods
elsewhere
let me ask you and we're going to wrap
up in a few minutes i know this has gone
uh plenty long so thank you very much i
look forward to editing it down to its
essence
we'll see we'll see it probably won't do
too much editing
well dr johnson do you go by dr johnson
[Music]
is it dr elizabeth johnson dr ayan
elizabeth johnson i know would be the
full yeah dr johnson occasionally i mean
you know sometimes a little
gravitas doesn't hurt when you're trying
to get your opinions heard
but you may call me ayanna
oh thank you ayanna
beautiful flower is that what your name
is yeah
it does which was very stressful for me
for a while because i was like well
that's a lot of pressure but turns out
there's like a lot of different flowers
and they're all beautiful and it's not
this sort of singular thing
so now i'm cool with it it's a great
name
so we could we could talk for many many
more hours there are all sorts of things
i'd love to ask you about we talked a
bit about offshore renewable energy
marine ecosystems algae biofuel we
didn't really get into
regenerative ocean farming we spoke
about a little bit
but we're already at two hours roughly i
don't want to chew up your entire day
what would you like to before we close
up
mention if anything any requests of the
audience anything you'd like to point
people to any complaints about the
podcast you'd like to lodge publicly
anything at all
this is like a question i should have an
answer to huh
i mean i sort of mentioned
much of the stuff right like
environmental voter project taking your
role as a citizen seriously
thinking about patagonia's action works
to think about ways that you can
volunteer using your specific skills
there's also a website called climate
based if you are inspired to look for a
job more directly in the climate sector
that's a a great list of job
announcements there at climatebase.org
obviously if folks are curious about all
these podcast episodes we're mentioning
how to save a planet on spotify
i miss that crew all the time they are
cranking them out and explaining stuff
and and telling us every week what we
should do to help and i guess i would
say for those who have trouble seeing
where they might fit into climate
solutions i know this is like kind of
lame but i would recommend the book that
i co-edited
with dr catherine wilkinson which is
called all we can save
and the subtitle is truth courage and
solutions for the climate crisis so it's
very forward-looking and it'll give you
these examples of all these different
ways that people have
creatively found to be a part of this
transformation that we need to have and
there's some comics and poems and stuff
in there too so it's a sort of works on
whatever level you want to approach it
with on a given day
and that i found really interesting to
help to curate because i really see it
as like 40 essays or 40 different doors
into how we can participate in climate
solutions it's not just
solar panels and electric cars although
i like both of those things there's a
lot more to this
and what i'm doing next which i would
say i guess like keep your eye out
is
i'm gonna stop doing
interviews on other people's podcasts
and write the book that i was supposed
to write last year
which is tentatively titled what if we
get it right
and it's entirely focused on
talking about the futures that we could
have if we charge ahead with all these
solutions that we have at our fingertips
so this visions of climate futurism
and i think that question
is so powerful like what if we get it
right like what if we do what we're
supposed to do like show me that it's
worth the effort because it is effort
and change is hard and like humans are
not often that interchange
and so thinking about it through that
lens i find to be really energizing like
what if we get it right you guys
like wouldn't that be great like don't
you want to be a part of that and so
i'll be doing interviews as a big part
of that book and i'm collaborating with
artists i have this very cool fellowship
through the headline center for the arts
to have artists help to
visualize some of the themes that i'm
working with and so
i would just encourage everyone to think
about that question what is the future
that we want
and how can you be part of shaping that
as opposed to fighting the past or like
the bad guys or against fossil fuels or
whatever like what are you for what do
you want to see more of
that is an excellent title i'm looking
forward to that that's a great title
you know you know
2023 stay tuned
and uh people can learn more about all
we can save at all we can save dot earth
pretty good url yeah
that is a it is a great url they can
find you on twitter and instagram
at ayana eliza
as in elizabeth
and they can find you
on your website ionaelizabeth.com
there's
urbanocenelab.org and then as i
mentioned all we could save
dot earth
how much fun this has been great
hopefully it wasn't thank you so much
for having me
punishing
and boring sturdy questions
thank you i'm all about sturdy questions
uh and
anything else you would like to add
step it up tim we need you
[Applause]
i'm working on it and i am going to be
and i am going to be stepping it up uh
thank you so much dr johnson you can
drunk text me if you need some hot
climate action solution boy oh boy yeah
trunk texting that is another
if you're going to ask what superpower
did i get from my parents it might be
drunk texting
not to be underrated that that sort of
like
that clarity
truth telling you know
a messy messy truth-telling
the mess of reality that we all navigate
sometimes you need a drunk text or two
and for everybody listening thank you
for tuning in you can find the show
notes links to everything that we have
discussed and more at tim dot blog
podcast and until next time thank you
for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy if you're not sure if your
meals or where they should be it covers
your bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive
and i do my best of course to focus on
nutrient-dense proper meals but
sometimes you're busy sometimes you're
traveling sometimes you just want to
make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e i have had so much
tea in my life i've been to china i've
lived in china in japan i've done tea
tours i drink a lot of tea and 10 years
plus of physical experimentation and
tracking has shown me many things
chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where tea is going to tie
into this it affects immune function
weight management mental performance
emotional health you name it i've been
drinking fermented poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now poo air tea delivers more
polyphenols and probiotics than you can
shake a stick at it's like providing the
optimal fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to find
real poo air that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why peaks fermented
poo air tea crystals have become my
daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them through my friends dr peter
attila and kevin rose peak crystals are
cold extracted using only wild harvested
leaves from 250 year old tea trees i
often kick start my mornings with their
poor green tea their poor black tea and
i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the black specifically
is amazing it's very very it's like a a
delicious barnyard
very peaty if you like whiskey and stuff
like that they triple toxin screen all
of their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic molds contaminants
commonly found in tea there's also zero
prep or brewing required as the crystals
dissolve in seconds so you can just drop
it into your hot tea or i also make iced
tea and that saves a ton of time and
hassle
so peek is offering 15 off their
purity's for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer simply visit peaktee.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available to listeners of this
podcast that's peak t dot com forward
slash tim the discount is automatically
applied when you use that url you also
have a 30 day satisfaction guarantee so
your purchase is risk free one more time
check it out peek t that's p i q u e t e
a dot com slash time
[Applause]
you